hello everybody in today's video I'm
going to talk to you about how epsil
selects its stuff
more specifically how we select our
permanent officials
you may have heard that recently we have
adopted a new competition model
introducing a faster and leaner and more
accessible way of selecting staff
you'll find information about this new
approach on our website here you may
know that we offer a variety of
contracts to come and work with the EU
but today I'm going to focus on the
competition through which you can become
a civil servant or a permanent official
we have two types of competitions
available we have what we call the
generalist competition which is open to
all fields
you do not need work experience you only
need minimum a university bachelor
degree
we offer these competitions at grade 85
which is the entry level grade for a
career as a graduate in the EU
institutions
then of course we also have what we call
specialist competitions and for these
competitions you need a degree in the
field of the competition and you need a
number of years of experience also in
that field for instance 86 would mean
you need for instance a master degree
plus three years of experience or a
bachelor degree plus four years of
experience and 87 competition requires a
master plus six or a bachelor plus seven
years of experience in that field of the
competition
now as we said the competition has a new
structure a new model let's have a look
at how this model looks like
first of all the length of the
competition has been reduced between the
application periods and the time we
publish the reserve list the list of
successful candidates there will be
about six months time
so as soon as we have published an
opportunity a competition on the website
you will have an application period of
about four to five weeks during which
you can apply for this competition
online on the website
everybody who validates his or her
application in time will be invited to a
set of tests
you will sit these tests in one single
day that's also a novelty it used to be
different stages over different months
we now make you sit all the tests in one
single day
you will set your test tests remotely so
you do not any longer have to travel to
a test center to sit your tests you sit
them from home or from anywhere else
from your computer and your tests will
be proctored they will be remotely
proctored basically meaning there will
be they will monitor you when you sit
your tests you will have to show that
you are alone in the room and make sure
that we see that you don't have help or
assistance of course to sit your tests
how does this single day testing look
like you will sit three tests first of
all you we test your reasoning skills we
test your verbal numerical and abstract
reasoning skills through a set of
multiple choice questions
and you can train this and I suggest you
do train this if ever you want to take
part in a competition and you can do so
on our website we have sample tests
available in the 24 languages
so please go have a look there and you
guys familiar with the level of
difficulty of these questions there's
also a Time factor involved so you have
to be able to solve these questions
under time pressure and by doing this uh
by training this you get better at this
as I said you will be able to choose
your language in which you want to see
these tests one of the 24 official
languages and you can indicate this in
your application form
for generalists the second test will be
an EU Knowledge Test so we will test
your knowledge about the EU institutions
the different institutions the
procedures the different policies at
stake also different priorities we
currently have and how these
institutions collaborate
how can you prepare for these tests once
we have published the competition we
will also publish a list of links
redirecting to pages on the Europa
website from which we will draw the
questions so basically you have the
study material at hand you can read and
study this material to prepare yourself
for this test it will also be a multiple
choice question test
the result of which will be ranked so
here you have to score amongst the best
uh of all participants taking part in
this competition
for Specialists we will assess the
knowledge in the field of the
competition again through a multiple
choice question test
the third test will be a written
exercise it can be a case study or
another form of written tests during
which we may test four General
competencies
on this slide you see eight competencies
listed and through this written exercise
we of course we can assess a written
communication and we may test another
couple of competencies that you will see
mentioned on this slide these are the
competencies that you will need to
display or demonstrate throughout your
career and as I said some of them might
be tested through this written exercise
the one scoring best overall will be the
ones listed on this Reserve lists and
they are the ones that then can be
recruited so that's the next step then
once you are on this list of successful
candidates
you can be recruited as I said when an
institution has a vacancy they will
consult this list of successful
candidates and try and find a match
between the vacancy and the people on
the list so they will have a look at the
CVS on the list
and invite four or five people who seem
to match the vacancy to a job interview
the best match will be offered the job
and the others stay on the list so once
you are chosen for a certain vacancy you
can be recruited and you can start your
career in the EU
this is what I wanted to share about
this new competition model with you if
you have more questions have a look on
the website first because we have a page
dedicated to this new competition model
if you have more questions you can
always reach out to us through the
contact form on our website and please
follow EU careers on our social media to
stay up to date on upcoming
opportunities thanks for your attention
and see you next time bye